i want to talk a little bit more about
reflection and specular and diffuse
reflection in particular and to start
off i want to make a minor correction to
the last video and it's actually an
interesting correction because in this
image right here when i talked about a
double reflection i talked about the
light from the sun hitting this pond or
specularly reflecting off of the surface
of this pond and then reflecting off of
this paddle to get to our eye and when i
said where the light ray was passing i
said in the last video i said it goes
from the sun to this point to this point
on the surface because that's where we
saw the reflection and i said then from
that point to this point on the paddle
and then to our eye and the correction
here and someone pointed this out on the
message board and it was a very good
catch is that this point is where the
the light is reflecting to our eye so
and that's because we see it we see the
sun there so this light right here is
coming directly to
directly to someone's eye let me draw
someone's eye right there are our eye
our eyes kind of coming straight out of
the page the light that got reflected
here it's going to be reflected a little
bit more shallowly so it came from the
sun
it came from the sun obviously this
won't be exact but it came from the sun
it probably had a slightly more shallow
angle of incident or or angle between
the ray and the surface and then it
would have gotten to
then it would have gotten to the paddle
and then it would get to our eye and i
want to make clear we don't see the sun
at the point that it was reflected
because that light that image of the sun
is going to the paddle which then goes
to our eye the point that we see the sun
the reflection of the sun that light's
going straight into our eye wouldn't
have to be reflected by the paddle so
that was an interesting and good catch
when you think about the double
reflection the other one thing i want to
talk about is when you have both
specular and diffuse reflection
happening at the same time and we see
this all over the place anytime you see
kind of a shiny object something that's
not a mirror but it's a shiny object and
we see that right here in the apple and
just to make this clear so you can see
this this white part right here which
we've all seen on a nicely waxed apple
this is it's like a reflection of the
actual light source while everywhere
else it's just kind of the color of the
apple and let's think about what's
happening here
so if i were to draw the surface if i
were to draw the surface of the apple
let me draw i'm going to draw it in a
neutral color so let's say we have the
surface of the apple right over here
we have the surface of the apple right
over there and then maybe i'll draw it
as a slight circle just so that you can
appreciate that it's a circular apple so
it's the surface of the apple right over
here you have some light source so you
have some light source so you have some
some light source over here and it's and
it's emitting light
so it is emitting light in some
direction onto the surface of the apple
and what's happening on the surface
apple there's there's a couple of things
that's happening you're having
some of this light is
is reflecting specularly or another way
of thinking about it is it's it's
maintaining the image a little bit but
not all of it so let me just draw it so
if you're coming in at that incident
angle you're going to leave
at that
reflected angle
and if you came in at this incident
angle you're going to leave at that
reflected angle
and if you came at this incident angle
you're going to leave at that reflected
angle i'm doing dotted lines to show you
that it's not all of the light that's
getting reflected that way only some of
the light is getting that specular
reflection but if someone if this light
were to be reaching your eye if let me
draw a proper
face so let's say that this is someone's
face right here
that's someone that's their ear or their
hair that's their eyebrows that's their
mustache
i think you get the general idea so this
person will see a reasonably good
version of the light source which we see
right over here but what's going on the
rest of the apple or even over here so
some of the light is reflecting
specularly it's kind of maintaining the
image of the light source although
that's also getting distorted a little
bit but the rest of the light
the rest of the light and let me be
clear here the rest of some of it is
being absorbed some of it is being
absorbed by the actual surface of the
apple but the rest of it is reflecting
red light what we see is actually what
the light apple does not absorb what the
apple is reflecting but that red light
that mainly red i mean it's a bunch of
different shades over here is reflecting
diffusely so that pure light comes in
here some of the pure light gets
reflected specularly or kind of purely
maintaining the image but some of it
because the the surface of the apple
isn't smooth is going in in all sorts of
directions so some of it's going like
that some of it's going like that some
of it's going like that and that's
happening at every at every point on the
apple so that light source let me draw
more of the light source so rays coming
in ray's coming in from our light source
but every point in the apple is also
having this diffuse react reflection
which is reflecting only the red part of
the spectrum it's absorbing it's
absorbing all of the other parts of the
spectrum and so what you see is that
point where you're getting the pure
specular the pure specular reflections
that's the point that looks shiny where
you can kind of see the light source and
from every other point on the apple
where only this guy right here is only
getting is only getting the diffuse red
light and that's why if you move the
apple if you're actually even better if
you move your where you're looking at
the apple that point of reflection is
going to look like if i start looking
from this direction i'm going to get a
different point of reflection because
i'm going to start seeing the light
let's see let's say that someone's
eyeball is right actually right over
here so that's their eyebrows that's
their eyeball
that's their nose you get the general
idea
so let's say this person let's say this
person that's their ear there i don't
want to get too involved and dry let's
say that this person is looking at this
super ginormous apple now relative to
him
he's not going to see this white spot
there he's going to see the white spot
on the point where it looks like where
he's getting the right angle where the
rays are coming in let me do it in a
different color so let's say let's say
the light source is above us so the
light source is coming straight down
it's coming straight down to the apple
and then if it's the right angle if the
angle of incidence and angle reflection
relative to the surface of the apple and
we can draw that out we can draw
perpendicular to the surface of the
apple this is the angle of incidence
this is the angle of reflection so at
those points at that point right there
he's getting a little bit and i should
draw a dotted line he's getting a little
bit of the
of the specular reflection but from
every other point so for every other
point on the apple so over here the
specular reflection would go that way
not to his eyes or it would go that way
not to his eyes but from those points
you also have some of the diffuse
reflection some of that is going to his
eye in terms of red the red part of the
frequency is getting to his eye from all
of these other random directions and
that's why this guy over here he would
see this this reflection he would see
this reflection roughly over here and
all of this other part of the apple
would look red we since we're on this
side of the apple we see the reflection
point the light is coming straight down
from our light source bouncing right
here and then coming straight out
towards our eye coming down and then
reflecting coming straight out towards
our eye it's also coming down on these
other points but those other points are
going straight out to some place where
our eye isn't and instead we're just
seeing we're just seeing the diffuse
part that is actually coming to our eye
anyway hopefully you found that a little
bit more
filled in a couple of the gaps of the
last video